g3 on the board okay
and this one is also a little bit
personal because judy said richard would
win so let's see i said magnus would win
so let's see actually it was interesting
i had lunch with rapper today
and we are discussing i asked him
whether what do you think about
what do you think about the
is it better to play with white or is it
better play for
look this is funny because they play
kings in the end with the other
reversed
this is funny
yeah
okay so we have
reversed kings in the end
on the board and they are playing very
fast so right now knight g5 forcing
magnus to give up his bishop
which is not that important necessarily
but let's see after a white bishop moves
away what will be the move
by magnus so i was discussing with the
rapport that which is better to play
with the white or the black pieces it's
not that you have an option right to
choose but still just in principle and
and he said well maybe it depends on the
opening very much this was one of the
remarks he said that if let's say white
has a huge advantage in the opening
then he believes that practically there
is no way back for black but you see how
aggressive he is i was going to say he
has done something that's very popular
in english chess which is advance the
age porn we've nicknamed it harry and
everyone is pleased
uh but it's uh it's ironic actually
because magnus is the one that
needs to draw he just he would be happy
with keeping the position quite soft yes
but this is not the kind of position you
just sit and wait and play for a draw
yeah this this is not that type of game
but it's interesting that he goes h5 h4
and i think specifically he does this
strategy against rapport there would be
also a very sensible idea to play with
black instead of h4 to play b5 push the
knight back to a3 and simply play a6
this is a very typical idea so why did
not have time to play a4 until this
moment
but now let's see queen e1 so the idea
is he's keeping an eye on the king's
side so 2 vs the g3
and also if after b5 now already knight
a5 would be the move
and
so so now b5 already is not
unpleasant
very sharp game very interesting game
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if in the
next move right we just simply
plan to capture the pawns so now it's a
question how magnus we react because if
he takes on g3 maybe queen g3 this was
going to be my answer actually i would
instinctively like to open the h line
after all that was the yeah but now
white has great
position of his screen because he's
pushing a little bit on the g file on
the diagonal so f6 e5 okay we see a
captcha and uh yeah we're gonna see
queen takes porn and i was wondering on
the board
what happens if magnus just goes
it's water maybe now b5 no castles
and now
i kind of like this position for black
yeah yeah yeah i i completely understand
your feelings because eventually at one
time black can capture the knight on c4
capture on f4 and put his knight to e5
centralized and then it would be a very
nice position from black side
sorry
okay so castle
b3 richard plays b3
well white is really provoking black to
be playing b5 and i i'm waiting that
that when is the moment when magnus
decides to play b5 because if the white
knight is pushed back to b2 of course
after that he will want to play a4 and
open up the position but the knight on
b2 is really not standing
so proud on b2 there
and
can magnus actually afford to forget
about the queen side and just simply
concentrate on opening up even more
lines on on the king side what do you
have in mind so okay first of all maybe
developing the knight
i don't know if you can develop twists i
was thinking a
h6
i don't like the knight on h6 yeah
it's not it doesn't make the best
impression i admit that but i thought
maybe we could move to knight c f7 and
then
from there no it's a question where that
knight should be moving to
that's a big question
oh
and he went 1986.
yeah because 97 was
probably something he didn't like he
didn't want to leave his knife
so what was the material
and now it's a question whether to play
bishop c4 first because this is a very
serious question take take and then
knight e5
and then later on you can go knight f7
to stabilize the knight on e5 as well
but he took back without capturing that
yeah
i'm not sure about this i i would try i
think bishop c4 which doesn't mean
that's the best
but
it takes okay
pawn takes
i don't know
and
what to do
now
for both sides actually
for magnus i feel it's what about the
queen g6
okay
is this maybe
six or uh rook f3 for example
doubling on the f5
what did he play c3
very interesting though
very interesting because this king on c8
of course can get in trouble if the c
line opens up i think very interesting
idea and the knight is far away on h6
i could think magnus was very honest
moving his kingdom and look at this time
look at the time seven minutes for white
and only three minute and ten seconds
for magnus and this is what we were
discussing that the time is extremely
tricky yes extremely tricky and of
course the players richard told us last
night that
they are thinking about getting to move
40 all the time so
magnus jumping forward with his knight
pawn takes pawn played very quickly
and uh magnus reacting with this looks
extremely dangerous for black it looks
like killing bishop f4 rook c1 oh
bishop f4
and uh queen moves to e7 so magnus's
trademark here is whenever he's a little
bit
a little bit in trouble he tries to swap
off queens but yeah rick c1 and then
guess
b
rook c1 b4
oh
yeah
well there's another question whether h3
and then black has to give up his pawn
with knight e3 i think
but probably after h3 he just wants to
go g5 yeah i'm not sure
okay no but this this was misplayed by
magnus i have i don't i cannot imagine
that this is possible to play it with
black yeah
i mean this is impossible to have your
king on c8 having rook on c1 having this
bishop on f4
it's
it is really deadly dangerous okay
and uh can magnus try to survive
somewhat i think if he goes he goes
knight f knight h2 even just playing
rook c5 and rook c1
would be a huge advantage not to talk
about rook f2 and he doubles and plays
b4 he plays g5 so it's uh
i think it's a must probably it's an
only move
oh and i think you're right i think rook
takes poorness well he that's what he
should do already yeah bishop looks like
he takes five and then rick c1 and
and he's not going to take rook c5
he is and he is
rook h2
it's a lot of fun
this game is a lot of fun and i don't
know who is better no why it has to be
better right
well i don't know i think bishop g5
but of course
it's tricky rook g8 queen d6
and how to defend
rook h2
i like bishop t bishop g5 okay
well this is the problem for black
whether if he has to keep his rook on d7
that's not a good sign
but because after rook d7
can white play bishop
h3
right
uh-huh and after rook h7 when you have
all these kind of checks i was even
thinking something like this
bishop h3 is a nice move because check
and take some and that will be game over
some tactical fun
g8 queen d6 so things are speeding up
magnus has no time left
takes well this rook must
it should fall off right king moves
to d8 white has time to think
at the same time it's not so easy to
the rook is
still alive on g5
but what about playing queen d6
queen d6 king
eight then white can grab the pawns on
with queen b7
yeah just play queen b ajak and grab i
agree
be ruthless
and of course black actually isn't
threatening anything because
king eight
i think it's about time to take queen b8
and grab the pawns
well if white can
oh it's a draw knight e5 oh
and now rook g1 is not a perpetual check
or is it it is yeah because
and now he goes there and queen f6 queen
f3
so magnus oops
and white lost
oh damn
the king goes to g g one only
or maybe yeah still there's no checks no
he's um
queen d1 or something oh dear queen f4
much better move but this will not be
possible to win
gosh
it's like magnus is just managing to
ride his luck it's unbelievable yeah
unfortunately for white he's not going
to be able to do anything apart from
making a draw
okay there's still 15 but he played so
fast he still has four minutes
you know
yeah we will have to show you that's
that critical moment because
it was a fantastic game i just when he
played bishop f3 i just wanted to say
that white has to be careful with bishop
f3 because i was thinking i will show
you
okay i mean there's still some chances
whilst uh well there is no chance to win
this game for white for black yes there
it goes
so magnus carlsen
draws the game
and this means that because it was an
armageddon match
magnus will take home the one and a half
points